[music playing]
This ladder's-- this
thing is janky, man.
If we're going to
go the distance
to get to a place like
this, then I'm going to go
the distance when I'm there.
I mean, you gotta check
every nook and cranny
behind every piece of plywood.
You gotta get in the attic.
You gotta get in the basement.
I was looking to see if
any of these are signs.
You'd be surprised
how many times
we see stuff from people that
use signs that have repairs.
Repaired stuff.
Good ones, too, you know?
MIKE: You gotta do your
due diligence, man.
I mean, those are the kind
of places that you think
about when you're driving down
the road, and you're like,
ah, I wish I would
have checked the attic,
or I wish I would've done this.
There's nothing up there.
[laughs]
I don't want to
second guess myself
when I leave this building.
I want to see it all.
This is a base for
a clothing rack.
And the top of this is
downstairs in Laura's room.
Because I remember,
when I walked
in, downstairs, on the second
floor, I saw her to the left.
To the right, on the floor,
is the top to this rack.
When I'm looking
through a lot of stuff,
I'm basically creating
a Rolodex in my mind
of parts and pieces of things.
For some reason, I can
remember where I saw something.
And then when I
see something else,
I can remember that piece I saw.
And then I put the
two pieces together.
You know, it's always been a
hands-on memory thing for me.
Turn a page in a book,
you know, I'm snoozing.
But when I'm waist deep
in it, I come alive.
It's great.
How much do you want for this?
And then she can
have the whole thing.
DAVID: Throw me out something.
- 100 bucks.
- OK.
OK.
So 100 bucks.
The top without the bottom
is really no big deal.
You know, but when you
put the two together,
it's something again.
And I want Laura to have this.
We would never have found
this place without her.
Laura.
LAURA: Ooh.
Look what I found.
What did you find?
Look what I bought you.
LAURA: You bought that for me?
- And then look.
- Are you kidding?
The reason I bought you
that is because you have this.
LAURA: Oh, no.
I didn't even see that.
MIKE: She's a vintage
clothing buyer.
But she saw all
this other stuff,
and she realized she
wasn't going to buy it.
- Oh, [inaudible].
- Oh, this is really happening.
So she turns another
dealer onto it.
And that's what we
do in our industry.
We help each other out.
Because at the end of
the day, isn't that
what it's all about, not just in
business, but in life as well?
You being in the clothing
business and all--
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
I thought it was really
nice that Mike completed
that clothing rack for me.
It was kind of like
scratching my back.
David.
DAVID: Yes.
Was this inside the store?
I really don't know.
The two sisters were
great collectors.
They would go to auctions
and country farm sales.
And I don't know.
It could have come
from anywhere.
This is a great piece,
because it's specific enough--
pottery-- but it's
also broad enough--
any kind of pottery.
Pottery collectors would
absolutely love this sign.
It's double-sided, and
it's weathered enough
to where you can see its age.
Is this something I
can make you an offer on?
Sure, why not?
Um, 300.
Mm.
350?
Hm.
I'm just wondering how much
it's going to clean up.
I'll tell you what.
Why don't we settle on 325?
OK.
MIKE: We doing this?
- Makes a deal to me.
- All right.
We're doing it.
We have found some
great stuff here.
But what I want to do is ask one
more time about the Keds shoe.
Let's get back into the
shoe department here.
All right.
The last time we were down
here, I got a little crazy
and offered you a
grand for the shoe.
This would have
been in the store,
letting the customer know that
they represent Keds brand.
So what are you thinking?
Well, I think you're crazy,
but we'll do the 1,000.
- You going to do it?
- We're going to do it.
- We're getting crazy together?
- We're going to get together.
- Let's get crazy together.
- All right.
We're getting crazy together.
I never see displays like this.
And it's perfect.
A lot of people collect
vintage clothing.
A lot of people
collect vintage shoes.
And when you look at something
like this that's made
this well, it's a piece of art.
It really truly is.
David.
Super careful.
Thank you, my friend.
DAVID: I think when you find
somebody that appreciates
it and you know will
take care of it,
it sort of gives you
a warm, good feeling
to know that it's going
on to the next generation.
I'll get over it.
[laughs]
When you get the museum
and everything all done--
Come back in two years.
[laughs]
All right.
MIKE: This building has a
tremendous amount of history,
and it's had a lot
of different uses.
And it's had to, in order to
stay relevant in the community
and to stay competitive
in industries
that are constantly changing.
- Thank you so much.
- God bless you, my friend.
- Thanks, David.
- It's been a real thrill.
Dave understands
that, and he's
willing to carry on
the family tradition,
not just for himself,
but for the community.
[horn honking]
Good luck, David!
Bye bye.
Safe trip.